Miley Cyrus talks Liam Hemsworth and  vows to never walk a red carpet again  quote why when people are starving am I  on a carpet that's red because I'm  important because I'm famous that's not  how I roll and I will never do a red  carpet again my psy is white hot on the  October cover of Elle and look at these  pics from inside the mag 24 year old is  chic and elegant in sheer white lace in  this series of pics and in this photo  her engagement ring is on full display  everyone's happy I'm happy Miley talks  about her man revealing that he's  obsessed with the latest screaming trend  Pokemon go quote Liam woke up and tried  to go to the car wash because it was a  what do you call it hooky spot but she  says she's not as good with technology  she's not even on snapchat but good news  with you guys she might start just  directing what the kids are really  feeling right now